it's time for this week's pet project
and lori herron joins us from the nspca
and she brought along someone who needs
a safe and caring home she's actually
got a pair of bonded cats harlequin and
sophie hey lori tell us about the cats
hey jc look at these two beautiful girls
these are two somewhat shy
siamese sisters how do you like that for
some alliteration
they are beautiful you can see their
links point siamese and you know what
jc they just became available for
adoption today at nevada spca and
because they're a little shy we really
want to find them a home right away
because they'll do so much better in a
home they're healthy they are bonded and
we make that decision when we decide the
animals will do better when they're with
each other and their sisters and their
best friends so how much better does
that get they're five years old and they
are
long haired we did shave them down when
they came into the shelter unfortunately
they were heavily matted but we took
care of them so their hair is growing
back beautifully and they will adapt
wonderfully in your home
lori they are gorgeous i'm just staring
at these two beautiful cats they're so
calm they're so peaceful they're very
young as well if someone's watching and
they currently have cats what's the best
way to to have the introduction how do
you interact new cats with your current
cats
well we generally recommend if you have
cats that are shy like these two sisters
that you separate them and animals
unlike us leave first with their smell
so they're going to we recommend that
you
rub a sock on each of the animal and
interact that sock between the two
animals
and let them smell each other first to
make sure that they can get along these
are two shy cats so i don't know if i'd
necessarily recommend that they go into
a household with other cats they would
be a good addition to a household that
doesn't have any cats so they can be on
their own um and you're getting uh two
wonderful
cats so you already have a companion
there in your house if you adopt both of
them
again gorgeous cats about 20 seconds
real quick someone's watching they want
these cats how does the process work
so we're still adoptions by appointment
so go to nevada spca.org jc and make an
appointment and our fabulous adoption
team will talk to you about harlequin
and sophie and if they're going to be a
good fit for your family i love it lori
if i can reach through right now and pet
these cats they're the cutest things
ever
thank you so much thanks j.c
we appreciate it and if you're
interested in adopting a pet go to the
nevadaspca.org go to the website or call
them at 702-873-7722
rocky over to you